en 1940 c'est à des milliers de
kilomètres de son pays natal que ville
Léon Trotski
il fut l'un des hommes les plus
puissants de la révolution russe avant
de devenir un paria dans son propre pays
pire un homme à abattre
chassé de Russie puis d'Europe par
Staline il a trouvé refuge au Mexique
l'unique pays au monde ayant offert
l'asile politique à ce célèbre apatride
[Musique]
Trotski de son vrai nom lève David
branstein
mène à Mexico une existence modeste
entourée de sa femme et de son
petit-fils
[Musique]
malgré les tourments de l'exil Léon
Trotski continue à vouloir changer le
monde
sans jamais désarmer il consacre la
plupart de son temps à défendre ses
idées multipliant les attaques envers le
régime stalinien et vise en Staline
lui-même
toute sa vie trop de ski a joué avec le
feu mais contesté ouvertement le pouvoir
de Staline équivaut à signer son arrêt
de mort
et dans l'ombre un assassinat se prépare
Ramon Mercader sera le bras armé de
Staline
en ce printemps 1940 Léon Trotsky n'a
plus que quelques mois à vivre et il le
sait
[Musique]
en 1940 Ramon Mercader séjourne
officiellement à Mexico pourra faire
muni d'un faux passeport canadien
[Musique]
en réalité il est espagnol et c'est un
agent en mission pour les services
secrets soviétiques
[Musique]
Mercader évolue sous les ordres de
l'officier Pavel sous-doplatov
chef de l'administration des missions
spéciales
autrement dit des sabotages des
enlèvements des assassinats
[Musique]
sous nos Platov a été chargé par Staline
d'organiser l'assassinat de Trotsky
cette mission est baptisée opération
canard
et pour accomplir ce projet criminel
sous-do-platov peut compter sur
l'efficacité de ses services et sur la
détermination de Ramon Mercader
[Musique]
à Mexico trop de ski poursuit ses
activités il travaille d'arrache-pied à
sa biographie de Staline
Léon Trotski est un homme pour lequel
défendre ses idées est un combat de
chaque jour
jamais il ne renoncerait
durant 43 ans de ma vie consciente j'ai
toujours été un révolutionnaire et
durant 43 ans j'ai lutté sous la
bannière du marxisme
si je devais tout recommencer
j'essaierai d'éviter telle ou telle
erreur mais le cours général de ma vie
serait inchangé
[Musique]
dans la nuit du 24 au 25 octobre 1917
les bolcheviks assiégaient le Palais
d'Hiver à Saint-Pétersbourg et s'emparer
du pouvoir
[Musique]
Lénine présidait le nouveau gouvernement
Trotsky accédait au plus haute fonction
de l'état
[Musique]
pour défendre le nouvel état
révolutionnaire il fallait une armée
entièrement dédiée à sa cause trop de
ski créa l'Armée rouge et ce jeta dans
l'action sillonnant le pays à bord de
son train spécial pour diriger ses
troupes et faire triompher la révolution
bolchevique
[Musique]
pendant que sur le terrain trop de ski
se forge est une stature de héros
Staline intriguait à Moscou pour
l'évincer à la première occasion
[Applaudissements]
le 21 janvier 1924 le peuple russe tout
entier pleurait la mort de Lénine
[Musique]
ce jour-là trop de ski se trouvait à
milieu de Moscou dans un train filant
vers le Caucase contraint par ses
médecins à un repos forcé
Léon Trotsky était le seul dignitaire du
parti à ne pas assister aux funérailles
la nouvelle de la mort de Lénine se
répandait rapidement par ronde j'obtiens
la liaison par fil direct avec le
Kremlin juste cette réponse
funérailles samedi de toute façon on
arriverait pas conseillons suivre
traitement
en réalité les obsèques eurent que le
dimanche et j'aurais pu parfaitement
arriver à temps à Moscou
si invraisemblable que cela puisse
paraître on me trompe pas sur la date
des funérailles
tenir trop de ski éloigné de Moscou le
plus longtemps possible et le
discréditer aux yeux des Russes
permettait à Staline de garder les mains
libres pour avancer ses pions vers le
Kremlin
car si le testament de Lénine était
ouvertement défavorable à Staline il ne
désignait pas pour autant trop de ski
comme successeur
trop de ski qui était sûr de lui et de
son pouvoir ne rentrera à Moscou que
trois mois après la mort de Lénine
il avait toujours éprouvé un grand
mépris pour le camarade Staline et ne
pouvait envisager d'être évincé par un
bureaucrate inculte
il me répugnait par les traits de
caractère qui ont fait ensuite sa force
dans la vague de décadence et trois
tests des intérêts empirisme
psychologique grossière un singulier
cynisme de provincial
[Musique]
les deux hommes s'opposaient aussi sur
l'idéologie révolutionnaire
trop de ski prenait une révolution
mondiale
Staline voulait s'en tenir à la
révolution russe qui était désormais
achevée
en 1924 l'Union soviétique avait besoin
d'être reconstruite après plusieurs
années de guerre civile
dans ce contexte les membres du parti
choisir Staline au détriment de trop de
ski qui risquaient d'entraîner le pays
dans de nouvelles batailles
devenus chef suprême Staline retira à
Trotski toutes ses fonctions chef de
l'Armée rouge membre du comité central
membre du Parti communiste
à cette époque les exploits de son rival
étaient encore trop éclatants dans
l'esprit des Russes pour que Staline
prenne le risque de le faire éliminer
de façon inexplicable trop de ski ne
livra jamais de bataille armés pour
reprendre le pouvoir
on m'a demandé plus d'une fois on me
demande encore souvent comment avez-vous
pu perdre le pouvoir
cette question montre que
l'interlocuteur se représente assez
naïvement le pouvoir comme un objet
matériel qu'on aurait laissé tomber
comme une montre ou un carnet qu'on
aurait perdu
durant toute son existence faire la
révolution fut la préoccupation majeure
de Trotski une quête obsessionnelle dans
laquelle il entraîna toute sa famille
[Musique]
dans l'adversité trop de ski a toujours
été entouré de sa famille
[Musique]
depuis leur rencontre à Paris en 1902 sa
compagne Natalia est son nombre fidèle
elle soutient son combat révolutionnaire
et l'accompagne dans tous ses exils
Natalia lui a donné deux fils lève ses
DOF et Sergueï
[Musique]
Sergei lui n'aimait que les
mathématiques la littérature et le
cirque
il a eu aussi deux filles nées d'un
premier mariage Zina et Nina qui ont
toujours été en adoration devant leur
père
[Musique]
à Mexico en 1940 Ramon Mercader attend
les ordres de sudoplatov
né à Barcelone en 1913 Mercader est issu
d'un milieu favorisé à la fois par son
père qui appartient à la bourgeoisie
industrielle catalane et par sa mère
issue d'une famille bourgeoise d'origine
cubaine
[Musique]
Ramon est très proche de cette mère qui
affectionne l'alcool la drogue et les
amours libres
et lorsque Caridad se lia au parti
communiste il l'a suivi dans ses combats
après avoir vécu dans la haute société
et fréquentée les écoles pour élite
Ramon changeait brusquement de destinée
il s'enroule d'abord dans les Jeunesses
communistes puis au début de la guerre
civile espagnole en 1936 il s'engagea
aux côtés des républicains
les Soviétiques étaient présents en
Espagne où il soutenaient les
républicains contre les franquises parmi
eux un agent secret était
particulièrement actif qu'Auto
c'est lui qui recruta karida des Ramon
Mercader pour le compte des services
secrets soviétiques
[Musique]
Caridad devint la maîtresse de Kotov
ensemble il décidèrent d'un projet
diabolique faire de Ramones Mercader le
fils de karidad l'assassin de Trotsky
un comme un accord Kotov et sudoplatov
décidèrent d'intégrer la mer et le fils
à l'opération canard j'ai fait la
connaissance de Ramon Mercader un jeune
lieutenant qui venait de rentrer d'une
mission clandestine derrière les lignes
de Franco
[Musique]
appris que son frère aîné avait perdu la
vie en allant se jeter après s'être
attaché des grenades autour du corps
sous un temps calmant qui fonçait sur
les républicains
sa mère Caridad avait été blessée au
cours d'un raid aérien
le recrutement de Ramon Mercader lancait
la phase opérationnelle de la mission
contre Trotski
depuis sa jeunesse Trotsky pouvait
compter sur son talent de journaliste et
d'écrivain
au cours de ces exils l'écriture lui fut
d'un grand secours moral et politique
il écrivit plusieurs œuvres importantes
ma vie histoire de la Révolution russe
la révolution trahie
ces livres traduit en plusieurs langues
lui offrait une efficace tribune
internationale et lui assurer des
revenus
car malgré son isolement trop de skin
n'avait aucune intention de laisser
Staline le gommer de l'histoire
soviétique il ne renonçait pas non plus
à sa révolution mondiale
en plus de l'écriture il avait le talent
d'entretenir un réseau international
il avait toujours été en lien avec les
intellectuels et les personnalités de
son époque
en 1928 après avoir privé trop de ski de
tous ses pouvoirs Staline le fit déporté
à almaa au Kazakhstan une république
soviétique
[Musique]
son fils avait choisi librement
d'accompagner ses parents en exil pour
les soutenir
il devenait à 22 ans le principal
collaborateur de son père
[Musique]
même en exil trop de ski travaillait dur
il écrivait des lettres et des
télégrammes adressés à ses nombreux
contacts à Moscou et dans les autres
colonies pénitentielles
par tous les moyens possibles
les agences soviétiques ouvraient le
courrier tout en le laissant circuler
c'était un moyen de surveiller
l'opposant
mais au fil des mois les activités
politiques de Trotski étaient devenus si
intense que Staline y vit une menace
son rival remettait ouvertement en cause
la légitimité de son pouvoir
[Musique]
à la fin de 1928 Staline était convaincu
qu'il était dangereux pour lui de garder
trop de ski à Alma Ata
le fer assassiner aurait rencontré une
opposition de la part de certains
membres du bureau politique mais l'exil
est encore plus loin pouvait être une
solution
après 12 jours de tergiversation Staline
pris la décision de déporter son rival
hors d'Union Soviétique où il imaginait
que sans argent et sans soutien il ne
pourrait plus agir
[Musique]
comment ça alors pour Trotski et Natalia
un exil interminable et chaotique qui
finirait par leur être fatal
au début des années 30 l'Union
soviétique se trouvait dans une
situation économique et sociale
désastreuse
un échec pour Staline qui devint
dictatorial et rejetait toutes les
fautes sur les trots
c'est à ce moment-là qu'il a déchu
Trotski de sa nationalité soviétique
plus jamais il ne reverrait sa terre
natale
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas qu'en Russie que le
régime s'était durci
en janvier 1933 Adolf Hitler avait été
élu chancelier du Reich
pour Trotski qui était d'origine juive
les nazis au pouvoir représentaient un
danger supplémentaire
durant les années 30 le ciel s'était
assombri au-dessus de Trotski
il avait d'abord perdu sa fille Nina de
tuberculose puis quelques mois plus tard
son autre fille Zina c'était suicidé au
gaz à Berlin
Trotski accusa officiellement Staline
d'avoir poussé sa fille vers la mort
elle laissait un jeune fils Eva qui fut
adopté par lève ses DOF le fils de
Trotsky
[Musique]
Trotsky était sous le choc mais l'action
le sauva
il multiplia les provocations refusant
systématiquement de renoncer à ses
activités politiques et de se conformer
aux règles imposées par ces pays d'exil
[Musique]
entre 1932 et 1936 trop de ski vécu
successivement dans trois pays
différents dont il fut chaque fois
expulsé la Turquie la France
et la Norvège
cieux de ne pas contrarier Staline le
chef suprême de l'Union soviétique plus
aucun pays ne voulait de cette haute
encombrant or au milieu des années 30 sa
vie était de plus en plus menacée par
des services secrets russes prêts à
l'éliminer dès que Staline le déciderait
[Musique]
après son recrutement Ramon Mercader fut
envoyé en Union soviétique pour y
recevoir une formation d'espion il y
était entraîné par l'agent cotov l'amant
de sa mère qui devint son mentor Kotov
n'aura de cesse de le conditionner pour
qu'il aille au bout de sa mission il
restera dans son sillage avec karidad
jusqu'à Mexico j'ai proposé à Kotov de
passer un mois environ à former carré
d'adhérents aux techniques du
renseignement car ils étaient très
novices pour tous ceux qui touchaient à
des notions de base telles que les
techniques opérationnelles ou les
différentes manières de déjouer les
filatures et de changer d'aspect
[Musique]
en plus d'un entraînement militaire
spécifique Ramon devait apprendre à être
un autre homme
un personnage entièrement fabriqué par
les agents de Moscou
[Musique]
désormais il serait Jacques Mornard un
citoyen belge journaliste sportif et
profitant joyeusement de la vie grâce à
l'argent de sa famille
une fois installé dans la peau de son
personnage une nouvelle phase pouvait
commencer
l'infiltration des milieux trotskistes
[Musique]
trop de ski était arrivé au Mexique en
janvier 1937
il avait 57 ans
et lui restait trois ans à vivre
[Musique]
alors que trop de ski et Natalia était
devenu indésirable en Europe cette Diego
Rivera le grand peintre de la révolution
mexicaine et un fervent communiste qui
leur avait obtenu l'asile politique au
Mexique
[Musique]
à Mexico il s'était installé à la maison
bleue la maison natale de Frida Kahlo
l'épouse de Rivera
ils avaient été surpris du bon accueil
qui leur avait été réservé
après avoir vécu dix années noires dans
la hantise permanente d'être assassiné
c'était pour eux un moment de répit un
havre de paix et de vie
[Musique]
Trotski avait de l'admiration pour
l'oeuvre de Rivera
ces fresques monumentales rendaient un
vibrant hommage à l'histoire et au
luttes du peuple mexicain
c'est au Mexique qu'avait eu lieu la
première grande révolte sociale du monde
prémices à la révolution russe
[Musique]
le couple Rivera était d'une originalité
folle et entraînait dans le tourbillon
de leur vie leur évolutionnaire russe et
sa femme
mais malgré une existence exotique chez
Diego et Frida trots
la nouvelle qui leur parvenaient de
Moscou étaient épouvantables
les purges lancées par Staline depuis
1936 les hantais
à Moscou Staline liquida tous ceux qui
le gênaient
[Musique]
l'assassinat de son ami Sergei qui offre
avait été une aubaine pour lui
cela lui avait permis de désigner des
traîtres aux parties et de déclencher
une série de process spectaculaires
c'était une nouvelle phase de la terreur
stalinienne
à la loubianca le quartier général de la
police politique les cellules étaient
remplies d'accusées qui étaient la
veille encore des dirigeants influents
terrorisé et acculé par des preuves
fabriquées ces anciens camarades de
Lénine ses révolutionnaires convaincus
étaient devenus incapable de se défendre
et le procureur vichinsky se déchaînait
contre eux
les condamnations à mort pleuvait les
condamnés étaient aussi tôt fusillés
[Musique]
en 1937 lors de la seconde vague des
grands procès de Moscou trop de ski et
son fils lèvent ses dofes furent accusés
de vouloir saboter l'Union soviétique et
furent condamnés à mort par contre
humains
[Musique]
quant office cadet de trop de ski et de
Natalia Sergueï qui vivait en Union
soviétique il avait été déporté en
Sibérie et assassiné
il avait 29 ans
sa famille ses amis Staline intensifiait
la répression en titres et les taux se
resserraient autour de Trotski lui-même
dès son arrivée à Mexico en 1937 Trotski
avait réorganisé un bureau opérationnel
en engageant des secrétaires et des
traducteurs
à la suite de sa condamnation à mort il
préparait activement sa réponse au
graves accusations portées contre lui
par Staline
pour lui permettre de se défendre
publiquement son comité américain de
soutien eu l'idée d'organiser un contre
procès
présider par le philosophe John Deway
cette commission était composée
d'intellectuels de juristes et de
politiciens américains
[Musique]
la Commission des ways se tend à la
maison bleue au printemps 1937
[Musique]
durant 8 jours trop de ski fut interrogé
sans relâche une épreuve harassante mais
dont il sortit blanchit des crimes dans
l'accusé Staline
la décision de cette commission ne
changeait rien à la situation de Trotski
et de son fils lève CEFF qui restait
tous deux dans le viseur de Staline
[Musique]
en février 1938 lève ses DOF qui vivait
à Paris se plaignait de douleur au
ventre
son nouveau collaborateur le fit
aussitôt transporté dans une clinique
dirigée par un médecin russe
il fut opéré deux fois avant de
succomber
il avait 32 ans
après deux autopsies et une enquête
bâclée la police française concluait à
une mort naturelle
il semblait évident que le gouvernement
français souhaitait ménager Staline
le fait que le nouveau collaborateur du
fils de Trotski fut en réalité un agent
stalinien laissait planer bien des
interrogations sur ce drame mais son
rôle ne fut jamais éclairci
la nouvelle de la mort de lève cedov
frappa Trotski de plein fouet
il perdait non seulement un fils
mais aussi son collaborateur le plus
fiable
[Musique]
après la mort de ses deux filles et
maintenant de ses deux fils trop de ski
n'avait plus qu'une idée en tête
rapatrier au Mexique son petit-fils
sieva
[Musique]
à la maison bleue les relations entre
Trotsky et Rivera tournait mal
les deux hommes s'opposaient sur des
questions politiques
Rivera avait aussi été fâché par la
brève liaison de Trotsky avec Frida
le secrétaire est traducteur de Trotsky
Jean van eyes
Frida n’hésitez pas un peu à la manière
américaine agrandir le mot love all my
love disait à la Trotski en le quittant
Trotsky apparemment fut pris au jeu il
se mit à lui écrire des lettres il
glissait la lettre dans un livre et
remettez le livre à Frida souvent en
présence d'autres personnes y compris
Natalia ou Diego en lui recommandant de
le lire
ceci se passait quelques semaines après
les audiences de la Commission de ouais
fin juin la situation devint-elle que ce
qui se trouvait tout près de Trotski
comme en 7 à s'inquiéter
[Musique]
Rivera coupa brutalement les ponts avec
le révolutionnaire russe en perdant la
protection du peintre trop de ski
devenait plus vulnérable que jamais
or le danger se rapprochait de jour en
jour
en juin 1938 Ramon Mercader débarquait à
Paris sous sa nouvelle identité Jacques
Mornard
[Musique]
depuis sa formation d'espion en Union
soviétique il maîtrisait l'art du
renseignement et du camouflage
[Musique]
la séduction était un de ses atouts
majeurs et les services secrets russes
en avaient fait une arme
la cible s'appelait Sylvia ageloff
elle avait été choisie par l'équipe de
sudoplatov parce que sa famille était
proche de Trotsky
[Musique]
le plan machiavélique avec commencer
quelques mois plus tôt quand une
espionne soviétique avait approché
Sylvia pour gagner son amitié
puis sa mission avait été de la jeter
dans les bras de Jacques Mornard
[Musique]
celui qui se présentait à Sylvia comme
journaliste et photographe belge était
en réalité l'agent soviétique Ramon
Mercader
Sylvia était facilement tombé dans le
piège
son nouveau fiancé qui menait grande vie
l'emmenait dans les restaurants à la
mode les boîtes de nuit elle était
éblouie
[Musique]
suivant les ordres de ces supérieurs il
ne parlait jamais espagnol et faisait
mine de ne pas être intéressé par la
politique
Mercader jouait avec Sylvia la comédie
de l'amour
il obéissait aux ordres
[Musique]
le plan fonctionnait parfaitement ainsi
lorsque Sylvia du se rendre au congrès
de la Quatrième Internationale c'est
Jacques Mornard qui la conduisit en
voiture
l'intégralité de ce Congrès avait été
préparée par Trotski depuis son exil
il lançait un véritable partie
d'opposition
c'était pour lui un enjeu majeur
cela devait lui permettre de relancer
son mouvement politique et son projet de
révolution mondiale
si Mornar n'assistait pas au congrès de
la Quatrième Internationale les services
secrets russes avaient un autre agent
infiltré il savait donc tout des projets
de Trotsky
[Musique]
tissait une toile d'araignée à l'échelle
du monde pour qu'elle se referme le
moment venu sur Trotsky
[Musique]
à Mexico au début de 1939 Trotsky et
Natalia se séparait définitivement des
verras
il quittait la maison bleue pour
s'installer à quelques rues de là dans
l'avenue Vienna
menacée de toutes parts il vivait
désormais dans une maison aux allures de
forteresse
les allées et venus étaient très
contrôlées Trotski ne voulant rien
changer à ses habitudes
recevoir des partisans des hommes
politiques et des intellectuels lui
restait vital
[Musique]
c'est avec les visiteurs et les nouveaux
venus que Trotski déployait toute son
amabilité
il parlait expliqué en faisant des
gestes poser des questions et des par
moments vraiment vraiment charmant
puis plus on avait travaillé avec lui
plus il était exigeant et plus il
pouvait devenir brusque
[Musique]
la situation dans laquelle nous vivions
avait sa part dans tout cela il fallait
vivre des années ensemble jour après
jour dans un espace restreint avec des
constantes mesures de sécurité
[Musique]
tout était arrangé les visites les
sorties
vous me traitez comme un objet me dit-il
un jour
[Musique]
en perdant Rivera Trotski se retrouvait
également privé des ressources
financières du peintre pour survivre il
écrivait de nombreux articles de presse
et l'avance de droits d'auteur pour sa
biographie de Staline complète et ses
revenus
[Musique]
en cette période noire quelques rayons
de soleil filtrés parfois dans sa vie
la Quatrième Internationale lui avait
redonné espoir en l'avenir du trots
il y avait aussi des moments de bonheur
comme l'arrivée à Mexico de sieva au
mois d'août 1939
Natalia une nouvelle raison de se battre
il n'avait pas revu leur petit-fils
depuis six ans et c'est un jeune homme
de 13 ans qui arrive à au Mexique
si Eva était l'un des rares survivants
de la famille
afin qu'il puisse s'intégrer à son pays
d'adoption Trotski interdisait qu'on lui
parle en russe il fut également
rebaptisé Esteban
les Rosemère amis du couple Trotski qui
avait conduit Esteban de France au
Mexique ces journées 9 mois à Mexico
une parenthèse amicale réparatrice pour
ceux dont tous les amis et anciens
collaborateurs avaient été éliminés par
Staline
malgré ce moment de trêve tout semblait
indiquer que Trotsky était en sursis
[Musique]
l'éminence d'une guerre en Europe qu'il
présentait était une chose qui
l'inquiétait beaucoup
le 23 août 1939 la signature du pacte
germano-soviétique anéantisecrotski
[Musique]
signé par Molotov chef de la diplomatie
de Staline et Van rebondrop ministre des
Affaires étrangères d'Hitler cette
alliance était de mauvais augures pour
Trotski et pour l'Europe
[Musique]
le 1er septembre Hitler envahissait la
Pologne
deux jours après la Grande-Bretagne et
la France déclarait la guerre à
l'Allemagne
[Musique]
je me souviens d'avoir écouté avec
Trotsky sur un appareil d'onde courte la
nouvelle du premier torpillage d'un
navire anglais par un sous-marin
allemand tout cela avait un air de
déjà-vu
on s'empêche chez Trotsky la lassitude
de voir se répéter une catastrophe dont
il avait été le témoin en 1914 mais
aussi la foi que dans quelques années la
guerre amènerait la révolution
socialiste
alors qu'éclatait la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et que Staline devait diriger
son pays en guerre il ne pouvait pas se
permettre de garder en vie son principal
opposant
il donna donc l'ordre à soudo-platov de
liquider Trotski
sudoplatov et son équipe réagir aussitôt
Mercader fut envoyé à New York pour
vivre chez Sylvia hagelhov ce qui devait
lui permettre de se rapprocher de Mexico
et de Trotski lui-même
quand Mercader expliqua Sylvia qu'il
fuyait l'Europe pour ne pas faire la
guerre et avec un passeport canadien
acheté pour éviter d'être mobilisé elle
le cru sur parole
et quand il partit au Mexique pour
affaire
s'il y a promis de les rejoindre
[Musique]
lorsque Sylvia vint le rejoindre à
Mexico au début de 1940 elle fut
aussitôt reçu chez Trotsky et Natalia où
elle était très appréciée
elle s'y rendait régulièrement et chaque
fois Mercader la conduisait en voiture
il ne demandait jamais à entrer dans la
propriété
Argan qu'une rencontre avec leur
révolutionnaire russe ne l'intéressait
pas
[Musique]
peu à peu les gardes habituelles à voir
ce garçon sympathique et serviable
Mercader se lia même avec l'un d'entre
eux un jeune trotskiste américain du nom
de Robert schelden heart
et lorsqu'en mars Sylvia rentra chez
elle à New York Mercader n'avait plus
besoin d'elle pour approcher trop de ski
ce n'était plus qu'une question de temps
mais Staline était pressé il lui fallait
absolument réduire trop de ski au
silence
pour répondre à l'impatience de Staline
sous nos Platov décida à la hâte de
lancer une attaque à Mexico
dans la nuit du 23 au 24 mai 1940 vers
5h du matin une vingtaine de marmées
jusqu'aux dents prend d'assaut la maison
de Trotsky
dans leur chambre leur évolutionnaire
russe et son épouse sont endormis leur
petit-fils seva dort dans la chambre à
tenante
soudain
retentit une série de coups de feu en
rafale
les tireurs inondent littéralement de
balles les deux chambres à coucher la
fusillade dure de longues secondes
les gardes parviennent à faire fuir les
assaillants
[Musique]
trop de skin Natalia et sieva sortent de
l'attaque en état de choc mais indemne
Natalia a protégé trop de ski en
l'abritant sous le lit
l'affaire a un grand retentissement trop
de ski est accusé par ses détracteurs
d'avoir mis en scène cette attentat pour
faire parler de lui
mais l'enquête de la police s'oriente
vers le peintre mexicain David Alfaro
sicaeros
[Musique]
caireeros est installé un convaincu et
un tueur
il a combattu durant la guerre d'Espagne
dans les rangs des républicains
[Musique]
malgré l'arrestation de sicaeros et de
ses complices cette affaire concerne de
nombreuses zones d'ombre
l'une d'elles touche particulièrement
trop de ski car elle met en cause l'un
de ses proches collaborateurs
les assaillants sont entrés facilement
dans la maison
[Musique]
l'homme qui leur a ouvert et Robert
schelden heart le garde américain qui
est lié avec Mercader
contrairement à la police mexicaine
Trotsky refuse catégoriquement de le
considérer comme un traître
et quand le corps de Hart est retrouvé
dans la banlieue de Mexico Avec deux
balles dans la tête il est bouleversé
[Musique]
attaque mal préparé ou simulacre
d'attentats destiné à intimider trop de
ski et son entourage
une atmosphère lourde pleine désormais
sur la Casa Vienna
trop de ski c'est que Staline envers
d'autres tueurs pour l'éliminer
craignant une nouvelle attaque la maison
est sécurisée
les murs d'enceintes sont rehaussées de
nouvelles tourelles construites
à l'intérieur on équipe chaque pièce
d'une porte blindée
et des gardes supplémentaires sont
engagées
la terre d'exil du révolutionnaire se
rétrécissait toujours plus
malgré les risques trop de ski refuse de
se laisser enfermer
ces dents à sa passion pour les cactus
il s'offre encore quelques escapades
dans les montagnes désertes
[Musique]
la vie est belle
collait générations futures la nettoie
de tout mal de tout oppression et de
toute violence
et en jouissent pleinement
[Musique]
après l'échec d'un premier attentat qui
a mis Staline hors de lui sous de Platov
actionne l'agent préparé spécialement
pour tuer Trotski Ramon Mercader
Mercader n'était jamais entré dans la
résidence de Trotski avant l'attentat
manquer mais trois jours après cette
attaque il y fait son entrée pour la
première fois
trop de ski et Natalia l'ont invité à
prendre le thé
il souhaite rencontrer le fiancé de leur
ami Sylvia à
Mercader accepte l'invitation
il se montre à présent curieux de faire
la connaissance de Trotski et désireux
d'écrire des articles sur l'état du
monde
[Musique]
la rencontre se passe agréablement il
sera réinvité à la Casa
[Musique]
il commence à rendre régulièrement des
services comme conduire les roses mer
les amis du couple Trotsky de Mexico
avait accruz
un voyage de 600 km mais il est prêt à
tout pour rapprocher trop de ski
après avoir manipulé Sylvia il séduisait
l'entourage du révolutionnaire
ces gardes ses amis son petit-fils
ensuite il disparaît un mois entier
sa disparition d'éveille aucun soupçon
c'est un homme d'affaires il était
normal qu'il voyage
de ce mois d'absence on ne sait pas
grand chose du parcours de Mercader
mais il est certain qu'il préparait
activement son action contre Trotski
soutenu dans sa mission par sa mère
Caridad et par son mentor Kotov présente
tous deux dans la capitale mexicaine
pour assurer la logistique de
l'opération
[Musique]
un peu plus tard Kotov devait me dire
que Ramon Mercader était prêt à
accomplir sa mission confiant dans son
entraînement de guérir en Espagne
pendant la guerre il ne s'était pas
contenté de se servir d'un fusil il
avait participé à des combats au
corps-à-corps armé d'un couteau
sa préparation lui permettait d'utiliser
trois moyens tu es trop ski d'un coup de
feu le poignarder ou le battre à mort
[Musique]
car il a donna sa bénédiction à son fils
le 20 août 1940 lorsque Ramon Mercader
traverse le jardin de la Casa Vienna il
se sent nerveux
[Musique]
il vient présenter à Trotski la nouvelle
version d'un article qu'il a écrit
le révolutionnaire avait rejeté la
première la trouve en mal écrite et
confuse
Mercader s'était senti vexé
[Musique]
trop de ski est occupé à soigner ses
animaux quand Mercader le rejoint
de loin Natalia remarque les deux hommes
en train de discuter
elle trouvait étrange que Mercader porte
une gabardine en plein mois d'août
trop de ski et Natalia commence à se
méfier de ce garçon trop mystérieux à
leur goût et envisage de se renseigner
sur son compte
mais ce jour-là trop de ski accepte
quand même de le recevoir dans son
bureau
ensuite tout se passe très vite
alors que trop de ski se penche sur le
texte Mercader lui fracasse le crâne
avec le piolet qu'il avait caché sous sa
gabardine
le crâne enfoncé est couvert de sang
Trotski mord son agresseur pour
l'empêcher de frapper une seconde fois
dans un ultime sursaut de vie il part
d'un même à se relever et à sortir de
son bureau
il intime l'ordre à ses gardes de cesser
de violentes et Mercader qu'ils ont
blessé il ne faut pas le tuer il faut
qu'il parle
[Musique]
dans l'ambulance qui le conduit à
l'hôpital trop de ski est encore
conscient
malgré les efforts du chirurgien qui
l'opèrent pendant plusieurs heures il
chemine vers la mort
la lame du piolet qui s'est enfoncée de
7 cm à cause des dommages irréparables
Léon Trotsky meurt le lendemain de la
taque le 21 août 1940
il avait 60 ans
le point final de l'opération canard
Staline avait gagné
[Musique]
bien des années plus tard les détails de
cet événement sont restés intactes dans
la mémoire d'Esteban volcoff le
petit-fils de Trotsky le survivant de
cette famille décimée par Staline
de la maison je suis une sensation
d'angoisse je sentais quelque chose à
quelque chose à normal arrivé des gens
dans la rue une voiture était arrêtée
je suis rentré j'ai vu que tout le monde
était bouleversé que qu'il avait quelque
chose de grave on est arrivé
par des policiers
il était dans un état tout à fait défait
pleurer gémissais j'ai jamais vu un être
humain de santé l'État
dans la chambre d'à côté d'ailleurs
[Musique]
le garçon ne doit pas si elle doit pas
avoir ça
[Musique]
Mercader n'a pas pu fuir comme le
prévoyait le plan
dans une voiture aux abords de la maison
ont finalement été obligés de
l'abandonner derrière eux
ils déclare aux policiers s'appelait
Jacques Mornard et être citoyen belge
une version qui ne changera jamais
sa véritable identité ne sera découverte
que 10 ans plus tard
[Musique]
dans sa poche la police retrouve une
lettre expliquant les mobiles de son
acte
[Musique]
il était important de pouvoir avancer
une raison pour l'acte qui devait
discréditer l'image trop de ski et de
son mouvement
l'assassinat devait prendre l'aspect
d'une vengeance personnelle de Mercader
contre trosky qui était supposé avoir
empêché Sylvia hagelhof de l'épouser
au cas où on leur est très merkader
devait aussi prétendre que Trotsky avait
cherché à l'enrôler dans un groupe
terroriste international dont l'objectif
était d'assassiner Staline et d'autres
dirigeants soviétiques
[Musique]
les Mexicains réservent un bel hommage à
Trotski une foule impressionnante des
fils devant sa dépouille
et plus de 200 000 personnes
accompagnent son cortège funèbre à
travers la ville de Mexico
[Musique]
si la nouvelle de la mort du
révolutionnaire russe Léon Trotski fait
le tour du monde
l'actualité reste dominée par la guerre
en Europe
[Musique]
après avoir fini ses jours en France en
1962 les cendres de Natalia ont rejoint
celle de Trotsky
tous deux reposent loin de Moscou dans
leur maison du quartier de Koyo à Cannes
à Mexico
[Musique]
Ramon Mercader est condamné à 20 ans de
prison la peine maximale au Mexique
durant tout ce temps les services
spéciaux de sudoplatov lui ont assuré
une détention vivable
après avoir poussé son fils à tuer
Trotski karida merkader fit de
nombreuses tentatives pour le faire
libérer
tout échouèrent
elle mourut à Paris en 1975
sous un portrait de Staline
Ramon Mercader reçut à sa sortie de
prison le titre de Héros de l'Union
soviétique mais en toute discrétion il
resterait à jamais un homme de l'ombre
il mourut d'un cancer à La Havane en
1978 à l'âge de 65 ans
il avait confié n'avoir jamais oublié le
cri poussé par trop de ski lorsque le
piolet lui fendit le crâne
[Musique]